speeding drivers cause around 11 deaths
or serious injuries on britain's roads
every single day leaving victims
families devastated
my next guest caroline cursop lost her
daughter anna
and unborn grandson oscar when their car
was struck by a dangerous driver in 2018
this footage shows the driver hitting
estimated speeds
of more than 130 miles per hour moments
before the crash
anna who was 38 weeks pregnant was
driving to her final
antenatal appointment and anna's mother
caroline
joins me now hello to you caroline thank
you very much indeed
for talking to us so it was the 18th of
december 2018
i think i'm right in saying it was your
60th birthday
anna was attending her final antenatal
appointment it should have been
a day of huge joy for all of you
and as we saw from that footage there
the very worst
happened just talk us through it
yes that day was my 60th birthday and we
had as a family
spent the previous weekend the 18th
december that year was a tuesday
and we spent the weekend um celebrating
my birthday
both my daughters and their families um
had come
to visit and we did lots of things
together to celebrate
not only my 60th birthday but
the arrival the anticipated arrival of
oscar
was very much on our minds and we had so
much fun
that weekend um celebrating
and thinking about the future and what
the future would bring
and the positive impact of another child
within the family
um anna went home on
the monday and i had um a text
conversation with about eight o'clock on
the morning of the 18th
um she wishing me happy birthday and
she'd left a little present from
my grandson her son um henry
um and we were just talking about that
and plans the day
my husband and i and his father david we
went out for the day
we um had a wonderful day
had went out for a beautiful lunch i did
some
shopping um i bought her some toiletries
handmade toiletries
and i remember having a conversation
with the
shop assistant saying you know these
were for my daughter who was just about
to
have a baby and i wanted her to have
a treat um so she could feel um
special after the birth and it was also
going to be her
35th birthday on the 7th of january and
we were looking forward to christmas and
had plans
um we then after lunch and after that
bit of shopping we
went to the eating project and i
remember sitting in the biome
with a hot chocolate listening to a
string quartet playing christmas carols
and actually i said to my husband this
is absolutely perfect
this was a perfect weekend and the
future
had so much to hold and when we arrived
home
later that evening the police were
waiting for us
um the last thing i absolutely expected
was for the police officer to tell me
that anna was dead i don't
it was just so surreal it just didn't
feel real
um i just couldn't take it in um
i remember phoning my son-in-law who was
absolutely desperate um
so much pain and shock i
had to get there immediately because i
was thinking about my grandson who was
two at the time
the police were so good they assisted me
to
get to my son-in-law and my daughter's
home
and there that's where i stayed for the
next six to eight weeks while we went
through
christmas i had to identify her body
on christmas eve um
and just working with the police on the
investigation
um her funeral was delayed and wasn't
until the 31st of
january we we saw
caroline um incredibly shocking
footage in the introduction to this
interview taken from a dash cam
of a lorry that that showed the driver
of the vehicle that hit anna
travelling at estimated speeds of 130
miles an hour and by the time
he hit anna's car traveling at more than
a hundred
miles per hour
i have i was so so shocked
um when i saw that footage and i still
look at it now
in absolute pure disbelief that anybody
could drive at speeds like that it is
just so
so selfish if that driver had taken
time to consider the possible
consequences
of his driving at speed anna would be
here now
oscar would be here and we would be
living totally different lives
the impact of him hitting anna from
behind
she was killed instantly and that is the
only thing
that gives me any peace is to know that
she did not suffer and that she did not
know what had happened
but when he hit her the force of
his vehicle hitting going into the back
of her car
concertina the car just squashed it
the car was pushed into a ditch but the
impact was so huge
her seat belt mechanism was broken in
three places
and she was then catapulted on the
vehicle
i know that she was dead before she hit
the ground
but i struggle when i see that because
when i see the cars coming to a halt
in that instant i know the accident has
happened and that she's dead
vulnerable lying in the wet road
um and that no matter what anybody was
trying to do to assist her
that she was dead and oscar was dead and
that our lives had changed totally and
completely in that instant
oscar no one yes i was going to say
the actions of that driver have torn
your family apart left you grieving your
daughter
anna's husband uh widowed and her son
henry
who was as you say two at the time and
how is he now
he's he's a remarkable little boy but he
is going to
suffer um he has lost his mother
in the most awful of circumstances he
had
you know he has was having an afternoon
nap and his mother never came home
and a two-year-old having to try and
explain that
and really extinguishing his hope
that his mother is ever going to come
back um
has been one of the hardest things that
i've had to do
and for him it will be an ongoing
experience
um as he develops and his understanding
develops he will need to go
through what's happened time and time
again
to reprocess it to understand it
to know what happened to his mother
um and that is really really tough
yeah incredibly uh tough indeed and
thank you for speaking about this we
appreciate it's incredibly
uh difficult but you want to raise
awareness
of the impact that speed can have what
is the message that
you want people to take away from this
caroline
the message is please please slow down
there is no
need to speed life is so so precious
please when you get into the car as a
driver
or as a passenger please think about
other road users
think about what you are doing the
possible consequences
of your actions if you drive at speed
there is no need for it
think about how you would feel if it was
your family
i can tell you that
i at times considered because my
children anna and my other daughter
would have to drive
for work to visit us family and i would
be worried that something would have
happened to them what i can tell you is
my anticipation my my concern
that something might have happened to
them does not even begin
to touch the reality of when i was told
that my daughter
was dead and my grandson was dead and
killed
by a vehicle that was doing in excess of
100 miles an hour
they didn't stand a chance no both anna
and
oscar your unborn grandson and
break the charity that you've been
working with on this
campaign have released uh
a survey and talking to people about
speeding one in three 25 to 34 year old
drivers say they've driven
above 100 miles per hour
in the case of this actually it wasn't a
young driver
that hit anna at all was it you know in
this case
the driver was 62 years of age
and it interestingly enough when when
the police officer came to tell me that
anna had been killed
um and that there was another vehicle
that
um had been driving at speed my first
thoughts were that it was a younger
person
and i was totally shocked when i um
discovered that it was
someone my age 62. um
but it it's not about the age
it's about being responsible when you're
behind the wheel of a car
the road markings speed limits are there
they're there for a purpose they're
there to support the driver and other
road users to make everybody
safe and all i can say is please
please adhere to them
look at them take note of them um
speed does kill
caroline cursop thank you very much
indeed incredibly brave view
to speak to us today and a really really
powerful message there
from caroline to drive safely and
carefully
and think of others caroline thank you